bienvenue à paris sur le toit du plus
grand centre de congrès de la ville qui
s'appelle paris expo porte de versailles
nous sommes à 15 mètres de haut sur une
surface qui fait quatorze mille mètres
carrés et nous sommes donc sur la plus
grande ferme urbaine en europe
[Musique]
ici nos tomates poussent en hydroponie
cette technique permet aux tomates de
pousser sans terre elles sont simplement
alimenté par un mélange d'eau et de
nutriments ce qui permet de leur
conserver toutes leurs qualités
gustatives et c'est vraiment la priorité
pour nous c'est vraiment d'avoir des
tomates et des produits succulent
[Musique]
nos tarifs sont vraiment compétitif
puisqu'il se situe entre le prix du
conventionnel et le prix du bio donc on
est vraiment sur les tarifs de n'importe
quelle production qu'on peut trouver en
supermarché nous avons une autre
technique de production qui s'appelle
l'aéropot ni on n'a du coup pas besoin
de terre et quand on est sur une toiture
et 20 le problème d'importance est
souvent un problème récurrent sur
l'essieu sur en toiture le deuxième
avantage c'est que on est sur la
distribution de l'eau en circuit fermé
ce qui nous permet d'économiser 90 % de
l'eau habituellement utilisés en
agriculture traditionnelle et puis le
troisième gros avantage c'est lié à la
pollution
les racines de nos plantes sont
complètement protégé de toute forme de
pollution en halo avec les nutriments
qui asperge les cinquante deux alvéoles
qui se trouve sur la colonne de culture
et sur ses colonnes en fait on se passe
totalement de terre puisque là vous
voyez on allait les racines qui sont
complètement à nu de du basilic là en
l'occurrence on peut faire absolument
partout ce type de fermes urbaines
il faut qu'il ya un minimum de surface
pour que ce soit quand même rentable a
paris il ya de nombreuses fermes
urbaines qui se développe en toiture
parce que il ya une volonté de la de la
ville de fleurir la ville est de
réconcilier les urbains avec à la fois
l'agriculture et leur âme et leur
alimentation
on arrive sur la partie ce qu'on appelle
déclaré parisien c'est des petites
parcelles de cultures qui sont proposées
aux parisiens et qui sont loués en fin
de compte sur la base d'un abonnement
annuel
donc on en à 137 qui sont tous loués qui
ont eu un grand grand succès après le
coc vide les gens ils avaient envie de
se ressourcer il avait envie de prendre
l'air il avait envie aussi de de se
reconnecter à la nature même si c'est
une petite nature malgré tout de mettre
les mains dans la terre de passer un
moment en famille avec leurs enfants
c'est quand même assez dense un
finalement
on a huit à dix plants mais bon alors là
par exemple la tomate elle n'a pas été
entretenu parce que elle aurait dû être
tutoré par exemple cette tomate la met
mais bruit c'est assez ça fournit pas
maintenant
[Musique]
ce modèle d'agriculture urbaine il est
compatible avec la vie de des urbains et
surtout il est complémentaire de
l'agriculture traditionnelle
on n'a pas pour ambition de nourrir par
une ville comme paris parce que c'est
une très grande ville mais on y
contribuer à notre manière cette ferme
urbaine ici elle incarne ce qu'on
appelle ici un peu le monde de demain un
monde plus résilient plus responsable
plus authentique
[Musique]